Wikipedia which you guys know it's the
crowd-sourced encyclopedia that we all
now go to for everything and basically
whenever you google anything the first
thing that comes up is the Wikipedia
entry they've made an admission that the
site is being manipulated by PR people
and what they're calling sock puppets
who are using false identities to change
what we thought were facts let's look at
a quote from the Wikipedia people it
looks like a number of user accounts
perhaps as many as several hundred may
have been paid to write articles on
Wikipedia promoting organizations or
products and have been violating
numerous cite policies and guidelines
including prohibitions against sock
puppet tree and undisclosed conflicts of
interests that sue Gardner who's the
executive director of the Wikipedia
foundation this has nothing to do with
real sock puppets I'm pretty sure this
is just a term that they're using this
doesn't really surprise me does this
surprise you guys at any level
whatsoever no I mean how this is now
just becoming a thing like anybody can
edit a Wikipedia profile anonymously
even like how did she say hundreds by
the way go and find hundreds that are
totally made-up yeah but I mean I think
it's interesting it that that that when
you look at Wikipedia anybody can create
those pages and you know oftentimes when
I have somebody who I'm interviewing
where I'm meeting somebody for the first
time I look at their Wikipedia page and
it is always just glowing
this guy's the greatest best smile in
elementary school I think that guy wrote
that right whose girlfriend wrote it or
whoever I don't know yeah yeah that's
not surprising to me right okay so we're
all agreed this is pretty obvious that
this kind of thing is happening so how
dangerous is it this the idea that just
the general idea of crowdsourcing facts
because I feel like nobody believes the
government anymore nobody believes the
mainstream media so now if we can't
believe our crowdsource facts who do you
believe actually that that's the real
question here who do you really get
facts from that you feel like is an
honest arbiter of facts besides besides
me the young turks an open report right
and of course
yeah I mean I just would compete in the
first place it is a great it's a great
tool for it but don't you think a lot of
people do yeah but I mean you can see
through some of it I say yes you know
but you never see something on Wikipedia
that's just really against somebody else
you know I mean it's pretty straight up
global you do though do really
interesting sometimes sometimes you'll
read something like your Wikipedia page
yeah no it's it's shocking that like
that this is now just becoming a thing I
mean I thought that publicists all the
time went to Wikipedia pages and I want
to know who this community of regular
Wikipedia editors are okay so let's talk
about that so there are 250,000
volunteer editors that these are the
guys that are keeping tabs on this whole
thing so is that part of the problem too
so it's not only that anyone can do it
but then the editing pool 250,000 people
that's a crazy amount of people again
250 thousand and then only 200 are
seemed to be not accurate yeah that
should be two hundred thousand times two
that they make every single day yeah
their high school teacher the geometry
teacher the local coach yeah okay so the
obvious answer then is that they could
have you register somehow and prove your
credentials or something like that but
then isn't the danger in that that it
takes away there's something about the
anonymity of it I suppose or there's
something about the the general openness
that makes it what it is so that if you
make people register you're gonna are
you gonna lose something I'm not to me
it seems like there's this surprise
about you know when somebody says what
do you mean the you know Facebook has
privacy issues or twitter has privacy to
go oh of course it does or Google is
actually looking through your emails
well of course it does anybody who
doesn't think that there's you know some
sort of privacy on the internet or some
sort of you know objectivity with
Wikipedia it's just I think those people
who are coming from it those are the
guys who built the Obamacare web version
of it yeah you know I don't for people
who grew up in the tech side I don't
think there's any surprise and you know
who are these 250,000 people who are
editing these pages there are they
professors are they Nobel laureates I
mean they're no I'm pretty sure they're
I'm pretty sure most of them are
unemployed because who what else would
you do you have the time I don't do you
have the time to be other people's
Wikipedia which you I wish I had that
kind of time too yeah all right but so I
sort of alluded to this early
really how much of this is sort of the
government's fault with the whole NSA
thing because we just don't trust our
institutions anymore I mean really do
you guys trust just the basic besides
our three shows of course do you guys
trust just the basic I don't even trust
MBC news you know back in the day they
would say if you lost or in Vietnam if
you lost Walter Cronkite you lost
America and it's like who do you trust
now that you would actually turn
something on and be like I mean John
Stewart I mean it's and Jon Stewart hmm
I mean I think it's anybody's game and
it's changing a lot right now but
certainly the traditional media hasn't
been working it's failed people it's led
a lot of people down and that's why
they're you know that's why what you
guys are doing is really great and what
Riots trying to do is really great as
well and when you see you know Vice
doing their thing and BuzzFeed and all
those and Gawker showing up and doing
great reports I think investigative
journalism maybe hopefully is coming
back what Glenn Greenwald is working on
coming up I think it should be in a
really interesting thing too but yeah it
has to change it can't just be this
corporate old media guard anymore
because people don't trust it pretty
good summation I know all right pretty
good hey guys don't forget the Reuben
reports brought to you by Cooper comm
they've got up to 75% off pet treats
toys and more and if you use code RR you
can get another 20% off that's a lot off
there is a link in the description right
down below code RR 20% off make your pet
happy